the last Voyage of the Demeter is based
on a short chapter of Bram Stoker's
Dracula but packs a horrifying punch
let's get into the reason why the cast
was too afraid to even look at the
Demonic Dracula how the massive ship was
built completely from the ground up and
how much intense training went into
being able to man a ship through a storm
something really cool about this movie
is they tried to keep everything as
practical as they could all of the
effects the intense storms the wind and
of course the horrific Dracula more on
that later were all done practically
they haven't spared anything trying to
kill us on board during storms and stuff
I'm honestly impressed everyone managed
to make it out in one piece I don't know
how I really should call my age or at
least my psychiatrist there was a lot of
pressure on the performers to deliver
because of the insane amount of huge
names behind the film one you might
recognize Steven Spielberg his company
is actually the one making the film big
hitters so we have to deliver the goods
overall though everyone did have quite
the Advent Adventure on set they said if
even one-third of their experience ends
up on the screen they have a fine movie
on their hands another element to
account for here is the narrative
depiction of Dracula this is the most
terrifying he's ever been portrayed in
the history of media there's never been
a story about Dracula as scary as the
last Voyage of the Demeter David dust
malcian who plays voichek believes that
in every other depiction of Dracula the
scary horrific aspect of him has always
been the one thing that's missing he's
always depicted in this cool erotic
philosophical way and they wanted to
Veer off a little bit from them they
really amped up the horror to give his
character the terrifying Justice it
deserves it all starts off with the
woman he kidnaps and imprisons on the
ship to use as his personal blood bank
for the month the crew rescues her and
that starts off a terrifying chain of
events and this chain of events depicted
genuine fear among the cast The
Practical effects on this set were truly
no joke the store forms were created
with wind and rain machines but the real
kicker was Dracula he's not depicted as
some good-looking tortured Soul like in
every other Dracula movie no the Dude
Looks Like a hideous monster I know I
mentioned before that everything on this
set was done with practical effects but
I just want to reiterate that Javier
botet was inside the Dracula suit giving
his castmates nightmares I'm not gonna
fight not just a one tank like but over
and over everyone was genuinely scared
of Javier in this Dracula suit people
were saying he was super hard to look at
so yeah that fear in everyone's eyes
it's not acting so what exactly made
Javier botet so terrifying well he's no
stranger to this type of work he scared
the crap out of people in movies like
Mama Insidious 2 Crimson Peak and
Slenderman so this Dracula suit is no
exception he's so calculated and
professional with the way he moves his
body he truly does become the character
even though everyone on set knows it's
him they can't help but be terrified
every single time the way he moves the
way he turns his neck the detail
detailed detail in this movie is so key
how much training do you think it takes
to be able to man a cargo ship during a
simulated thunderstorm actually quite a
lot the cast had to complete a sailing
boot camp before filming started David
desmausian had the upper hand in the
situation because he used to be a
professional fisherman in his early 20s
he was excellent when it came to
balancing on the ship but he couldn't
get a handle on the not tying portion of
the training he says he can barely tie
his own shoes let alone a professional
ship not Liam Cunningham cleverly
managed to get out of the Rope tying
exercise he was asked by the instructors
do you want to go up and start pulling
the sails up and that sounded a bit too
much like work to me and I went nah he
wouldn't do it he's the captain he
doesn't pull ropes so he just got to
hang out on the sidelines with a nice
glass of wine as he watched his
castmates struggle through the exercise
and leave with a palm full of blisters
obviously I have to talk about the ship
you would think they would use a bit of
CGI or visual effects but there was
actually not one ounce of that involved
they built the ship from the ground up
as one big piece so the actors could
live in it and get used to their
surroundings they also wanted the feel
of the ship to be really old and gritty
so they had people go over every inch of
it and sand it down to make it look worn
dirty and used the boat required a ton
of space to create what they refer to as
spatial tension and unreliable
environments that the actors would be
truly scared of they wanted to create a
world where you never would know exactly
which corner Dracula is creeping around
I would say they definitely hit the nail
on the head with that one after one too
many jump scares a handful of blisters
and getting drenched by rain on an eerie
cargo ship all day the cast and crew of
The Last Voyage of the Demeter delivered
a powerful terrifying feat what's your
favorite thing about this depiction of
Dracula